good evening everybody and welcome to
this overview and scrutiny committee
meeting as the crime and disorder
committee
good evening good evening and i've lost
my place in my product already which is
not a good sign is it
my name is council bell and i'm chairman
of this committee and before we commence
the business of the meeting there are a
few housekeeping issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate mitigate for
covid therefore can i ask all present to
work to the protocols agreed accounts on
2nd of september 2021 in the interest of
member and officer safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak
right i'll try and speak up as well
hilariously um please note that the
youtube live stream sound recording is
dependent on the correct use of the
microphones
um
so therefore when it when invited to
speak please turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is the
door behind this top table
which i believe we can get out of
tonight
now if i may ask officers and other
speakers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves starting with mr
holmes please
thank you mr clark
good evening spencer clark i'm the
community safety manager for modern
district council
thank you sergeant dolby is it
correct yeah sergeant that'll be from
the community protection team policing
team over at chelmsford
thank you
and
carl pull in please
um station age for more than burden to
humans holistically
thank you very much um any other
officers present
no not i can see
may ask those counselors in attendance
to introduce themselves please start
with cancer stamp
thank you madam chair cancer stamp the
leader of the council thank you thank
you that's morris
um
chairman sorry um you might say point of
order
uh councillor maurice please
you asked me to introduce myself and
she's interrupted i'm afraid i i've
probably interrupted councillor stamp i
believe i did interrupt you cancer stamp
and i do apologize for that thank you
madam chair could i just ask that we
don't have a running commentary i've
already heard a counsellor sitting on
the inner ring call an officer of this
council of snowflake i don't know what
he's just called me but i don't think
it's acceptable thank you madam chair
thank you what i have to say i don't
mind saying to anyone and what i did say
is that richard holmes is a snowflake
counselor morris that is i'm afraid i'm
afraid that's your first warning because
when she said leader is that she's a bad
one
she's a bad lady i'm gonna have to move
that you are not hurt that's right
would you like to turn that off so i
have to use this because i will i will
be heard i will be heard members
testing testing
okay
i shall move on now
can i middle
i shall move on
may i have the authorities for absence
please stewart
yes thank you chairman we've had
received no apologies for absence
tonight
councilor morris
point of older was you did ask me to
introduce myself as in attendance so
good evening what you did counselor well
not
why i not why i intended to introduce
myself why i intended you to no because
i was interrupted wasn't i but
councillor morris is sitting in
attendance for hayward west thank you
moving on
we have no apologies for absence what's
that stuart no apologies madam chair i'm
an apologist from richard please our
apologies from richard
thank you thank you council sorry was
that received by point of order was that
receipt
please was that received by the
committee or was that just put in now
because i believe that that
correct procedure is that the correct
procedure um chairman
members
i cannot answer that i'm going to have
to ask you again please
well counsel counsellor okay
i did
i am told that the procedure is that
when someone gives absence
it goes to
the committee clerk before the meeting
it's not just done in the middle of the
meeting when the meeting started is that
are we following procedure or are we not
following procedure i'm gonna have to
close the meeting i'm really sorry
members i'm going to have to close this
meeting because it's getting out of hand
i do apologize i do apologize to all of
you who take your time out this evening
to come
time is
7 00 35 and i'm
i can't take a point of order
mason is closed